In this problem, we'll be
looking at an ambulance that
is traveling back and forth
in interval of size l.
Say from 0 to l.
At some point in time, there's
an accident occurring, let's
say at location x.
And we'll assume the accident
occurs in a random location so
that x is uniformly distributed
between 0 and l.
Now, at this point in time,
let's say the ambulance turns
out to be at location y.
Again, we'll assume that y is
a uniform random variable
between 0 and l, and also that
x and y are independently
distributed.
The question we're interested
in answering is how long it
would take an ambulance to
respond to travel from point y
to point x.
Let's call this time T. And in
particular, we want to know
everything about distribution of
T. For example, what is the
CDF of T given by the
probability of big T, less
than or equal to little t, or
the PDF, which is done by
differentiating the CDF
once we have it.
Now, to start, we'll express T
you as a function of X and Y.
Since we know that
the ambulance
travels at a speed V--
V meters or V units of
distance per second--
then we can write that big T is
simply equal to Y minus X,
absolute value the distance
between X and Y, divided by
the speed at which the ambulance
is traveling at, V.
So now if we look at the
probability of T less than or
equal to little t, this is then
equal to the probability
that Y minus X divided
by V less than or
equal to little t.
We now take off the absolute
value by writing the
expression as negative vt less
equal to Y minus X less equal
to positive vt.
Here we multiply v on the other
side of t, and then took
out the absolute value sign.
As a final step, we'll also move
X to the other side of
inequalities by writing this as
X minus vt less equal to y
less equal to x plus vt.
To compute this quantity, we'll
define a set A as a set
of all points that satisfies
this condition right here.
In particular, it's a pair of
all X and Y such that X minus
vt less equal to little y less
equal to X plus vt, and also
that X is within 0 and
l, and so is Y.
So the set A will be the
set of values we'll
be integrating over.
Now that we have A, we can
express the above probability
as the integral of all X and Y,
this pair within the set A,
integrating the PDF of f of
X, Y, little x, little y.
Let's now evaluate this
expression right here in a
graphical way.
On the right, we're plotting out
what we just illustrated
here, where the shaded region is
precisely the set A. As we
can see, this is a set of values
of X and Y where Y is
sandwiched between two lines,
the upper one being X plus vt
right here, and the lower line
being X minus vt, right here.
So these are the values that
correspond to the set A.
Now that we have A, let's
look f of x, y.
We know that both x and y are
uniform random variables
between 0 and l, and therefore,
since they're
independent, the probability
density of x and y being at
any point between 0 and l is
precisely 1 over l squared,
where l squared is the size of
this square box right here.
So given this picture, all we
need to do is to multiply by 1
over l squared the area of the
region A. And depending on the
value of T, we'll get different
answers as right here.
If T is less than 0, obviously,
the area of A
diminishes to nothing,
so we get 0.
If T is greater than l over V,
the area of A fills up the
entire square, and we get 1.
Now, if T is somewhere in
between 0 and l over v, we
will have 1 over l squared,
multiply by the area looking
like something like that right
here-- the shaded region.
Now, if you wonder how we
arrive at exactly this
expression right here, here is
a simple way to calculate it.
What we want is 1 over l squared
times the area A. Now,
area A can be viewed as the
entire square, l squared,
minus whatever's not in area
A, which is these two
triangles right here.
Now, each triangle has area
1/2, l minus vt squared.
This multiply 2, and this, after
some algebra, will give
the answer right here.
At this point, we have obtained
the probability of
big T less equal to little t.
Namely, we have gotten the CDF
for T. And as a final step, we
can also compute the probability
density function
for T. We'll call it
little f of t.
And we do so by simply
differentiating the CDF in
different regions of T.
To begin, we'll look at t
between 0 and l over v right
here at differentiating the
expression right here with
respect to t.
And doing so will give
us 2v over l minus 2v
squared t over L squared.
And this applies to t greater or
equal to 0, less than l/v.
Now, any other region, either
t less than 0 or t greater
than l/v, we have a constant
for the CDF, and hence its
derivative will be 0.
So this is for any other t.
We call it otherwise.
Now, this completely
characterized the PDF of big
T, and hence, we've also
finished a problem.